um
so chuck what did you say about the nets
before the game what did what was your
hope in terms of kyrie irving uh i think
that he has to really consider getting a
vaccine because
kevin's out a month minimum as they said
four to six weeks so if we're realistic
it's a month
and he's only playing real games
they could
i how many games they play in the next
11 out of 14 on the road it don't matter
they playing homer road they they could
lose
they could they could they could be deep
to six seven eight uh
because they're not gonna win a lot of
games without kevin they're not in
they're not a good team that's the you
know all three of those guys
have to do so much of the heavy lifting
they don't have they're not good
rebounding they're not good defensively
they don't have a bench
they can lose a lot of those games with
kyrie and james harden on the court
the reason i asked the question
because i do remember what you said was
because kyrie addressed that after the
game tonight and what do we have
kyrie irving says the net's injury
situation won't change his vaccination
status i've made my decision already and
i'm standing on it well that's why i got
a title for my book but i'm right about
here
no i mean no no no he's but why would
you think i just my question is this
though only why would you think that a
month
of like winning or losing no no
decision
that's something that he like you know
but meaning like dad what he would have
he made that decision when they had a
chance well he's like we got a chance to
win it all
and that's at the beginning so why would
each i wouldn't expect him well
maybe you don't expect him to your hopes
and it's not just i mean i i would hope
he would have a selfish as a selfish
basketball fan without no no no no no no
no no no that has nothing to do with
being a basketball fan
i'm not saying that is he's uh i'm
listen i'm not i'm not giving his
vaccination stance or yes do i have
empathy for what he's saying and why do
i have sympathy no i think that you know
we've all realized now that the vaccine
is is really
it's a great seatbelt it helps all of us
stay alive for longer we realize that
but we also realize that now that
we could still spread the virus and so
it so i understand i have empathy for
his string his reluctancy i'll let him
take his stance but i wouldn't expect
him to change it in the middle of the
season no in this thing of us one it
doesn't last forever it's all about
sacrifice i hear the conspiracy theories
i did all that i sacrifice
i don't want y'all to get sick i don't
want my mama to get sick i don't want my
boys to get sick so i sacrificed for the
team
the big three was put together to win
championships
who knows what could happen next year
who knows what can happen after that
when you have that that chance can you
know when you got that slot you got to
go for it his stance is not going to
change because the same way you believe
that you sacrifice i'm not saying it's
i'm just saying what everyone's thinking
like
hey you're like wait you're sacrificed
for what because you still could pass
the virus that's what people are saying
who are not taking it
i'm just saying i'm going to do it
because i thought it was good for me i
think that it was going to protect me
better and that's all i could do i don't
care what he does i'm i'm just saying
that and in this thing of ours when you
want to win for your fellows and you
know everybody else is doing it
sacrifice plays an important role in
germany
yes and i actually you know
he talked kevin durant into going to
brooklyn
he talked to him before covet bro you
can't i i i got it no no no no no no no
i'm saying i can't say that no no but
i'm sorry if you talk if i say kenny
let's go to another network together
and then i says hey kitty you can sign
your deal and i changed i was like you
know what i think i'm gonna stay at
turner i don't think that's fair to you
that's just my personal view listen we
can let's i'm not i'm not talking i just
think that i'm not talking about this
dude anymore right
whether they i i just hope they lose he
had a season high 27.
i just hope they lose in a loss in a
seven-point loss to the cleveland
cavaliers